[Music]
for the future generation we need to
find solutions right now for a better
future because of climate change
and edible insects are a solution right
now
climate change is prompting a
re-evaluation of animal-based proteins
across the food sector
one company in switzerland is looking to
lower its carbon footprint by
introducing insects as their flagship
sustainable superfood product
my name is jean-yves quade i am owner of
entomos
we are selling a food product made with
edible insects
[Music]
in switzerland three types of insects
are allowed these are the mealworms the
crickets
and the locust
the insects they don't have a strong
taste the advantage is that you can
married with a lot of different
ingredients
anthomos who are producing snacks for
example chips or tortillas we are also
producing flour which can be used for a
bakery we are also producing a flexi
burger which is a burger made 50 of
mealworms and 50 made of beef
while using a sustainable product is
important for the environment for a chef
flavor is still the key element in
determining what to add to the menu
restoration
we know
[Music]
[Music]
if we are continuing to produce the food
as we are producing right now according
to the fao in 250 be able to
feed only 50
of the people on the planet so we need
to find new ways of producing food which
are completely nutritious and much more
sustainable
what is uh absolutely amazing with
insects is that they can transform the
waste we are producing into superfood
which is a completely
virtuous circle
every time a people is tasting the
product and having a smile is a great
reward and just
a great encouragement for continuing to
providing a better product for a better
future
[Music]